[Musique]
bienvenue je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de paris saclay
tv comment convaincre les entreprises de
rejoindre votre territoire de rejoindre
cet écosystème unique en son genre en
france eh bien c'est la raison d'être de
la sat paris saclay ça pour sociétés
d'accélération du transfert de
technologies en collaboration avec le
pead paris saclay cette salle a mené une
étude très fouillée sur la filière
intelligence artificielle
combien de start up de grands groupes de
laboratoires
d'entreprises travaillent dans ce
domaine
eh bien vous saurez tout grâce à une
cartographie très précise et vous saurez
aussi beaucoup de choses grâce à ce show
room technologique alors s'il n'y a plus
d'une centaine de start-up installés sur
le territoire qui s'intéressent à
l'intelligence artificielle il ya aussi
des grands groupes comme ibm ibm qui a
choisi d'installer ici son tout nouveau
centre de recherche et de développement
dédiée à l'intelligence artificielle qui
voudrait qu'il ya déjà des synergies qui
sont mises en place une délégation
québécoise quantique est venu sur votre
territoire elle a été accueillie par le
groupe atos et la hausse il s'agit donc
de développer des partenariats de faire
découvrir d'autres écosystèmes même
stratégie même volonté pour kimia lice
alors cette start up elle a été lauréate
du sprint 50 cette année dans la
catégorie santé et si elle a choisi
paris saclay c'est parce qu'elle est
liée avec l'école normale supérieure
vous entendrez son ceo cyril gilbert et
enfin notre agenda ce sera la fin de
cette émission
faut-il le rappeler l'écosystème de
paris saclay est unique en son genre
pour développer se clôt ce top pour le
faire connaître il existe de nombreux
levier la sat la société d'accélération
du transfert de technologie a pour but
de mieux faire connaître aux entreprises
donc paris saclay votre territoire en
collaboration avec le pea paris saclay 7
sat paris saclay a mené une étude très
fouillée sur la filière intelligence
artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle que l'on
peut retrouver grâce à une cartographie
très précise de votre territoire la sat
a aussi mis en place ce showroom
technologique
[Musique]
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui dans le
cas de la restitution d'une étude
filière ya que nous réalisons dans le
cas de notre activité de développement
économique est le père paris saclay nous
avons monté pour cela la sat à l'aspect
d'accélération de transfert de
technologie qui a une très bonne
connaissance des acteurs du territoire
et une vision aussi à 300° des
différents laboratoires publics qui le
composent au delà de l'objectif de mieux
se connaître l'enjeu c'est également
d'utiliser tout ce contenu pour mieux
promouvoir l'éco stand et paris saclay
notamment dans les actions que nous
allions à l'international leurs deux
participations à des salons
professionnels l'objectif principal
c'est vraiment de convaincre les
entreprises de venir rejoindre notre
écosystème
[Musique]
dans cette cartographie à paris saclay
nous avons répertorié l'ensemble des
entreprises sur paris saclay qui
travaille avec des chercheurs qui
produisent des retrouvailles de
recherche en y a nous avons trouvé 110
start up créée depuis 2010 sur ces
thématiques et enfin 80 à 90 entreprises
pme té i cant groupe qui travaille
fortement avec paris saclay sur ces
thématiques ja nous avons aussi recensé
42 laboratoire de recherche d'un très
haut niveau académique qui travaillent
sur l'ia sur plusieurs thématiques de ia
qui sont fédérés sur deux blocs qui sont
à y parisse le plus tôt pour ip pays
l'institut polytechnique de paris et
ensuite data ya plutôt pour l'université
paris saclay et inria et enfin et pour
conclure en termes d'indicateurs paris
saclay abrite 17 % des laboratoires
nationaux qui travaillent sur
l'intelligence artificielle mais 41% des
stars chercheurs entrepreneurs
confondues qui font l'intelligence
artificielle et un autre chiffre très
important c'est que dans l'appel à
projets de la nr sur les chairs en
intelligence artificielle paris saclay a
remporté 16 des 40 projets ce qui
correspond à 40 % des projets actuels
entre industriels recherche fondamentale
sur l'intelligence artificielle donc pas
forcément beaucoup de laboratoires
beaucoup de laboratoires au niveau
national travaille sur l'ia mais une
qualité importante de la recherche qui
transparaît à travers ses chiffres enfin
la sat met en place d'autres actions
d'attractivité du territoire typiquement
avec le showroom technologique qui se
visite
[Musique]
une porte d'entrée dans notre beau
territoire d'excellence académique et
industriel le showroom technologique
mutualisé de l'a7 paris-saclay du
playground est un outil marketing par
excellence qui présente la structuration
du territoire la complexité des échanges
entre ces acteurs les filières présentes
sur le territoire et a bien sûr les
technologies de pointe à travers notre
exposition des start-up l'avantagé la
singularité de notre showroom c'est
d'être vraiment en showroom transverses
qui est une porte d'entrée sur le
territoire qui permet vraiment a
rapidement comprendre les enjeux du
territoire paris saclay qui à travers
son exposition permet d'entrevoir
quelles sont les possibilités qui
s'offre à des acteurs nationaux et
internationaux
venant en visite sur le territoire et
travaillant dans les laboratoires de
recherche dans les lieux d'excellence
académique et industriel dans les
entreprises quel est l'intérêt d'être
présent sur ce territoire nous pouvons
le voir à travers l'exposition de notre
showroom technologique mutualisés
[Musique]
parmi les grands groupes qui sont en
pointe dans la filière intelligence
artificielle il ay ay ay bm ibm qui a
décidé d'installer son centre de
recherche et de développement sur votre
territoire à terme ce sont près de 400
chercheurs et développeurs qui vont
travailler dans ce domaine plusieurs
projets sont déjà lancées notamment dans
le secteur de l'imagerie médicale
entité qui se trouve ici ce plateau de
paris saclay est une entité dit bm de
tête un centre de co-innovation et qui
regroupe dans un premier temps une
équipe de développement logiciel
une équipe de recherche est également
une équipe de consulting
l'équipe de recherche que nous avons ici
travaillent sur des systèmes auto
apprenant que nous lions à des systèmes
de moteurs de règles business et qui
permettent d'appréhender des sujets tout
à fait nouveau en iran et puis nous
avons l'équipe de conseil qui va
accompagner nos clients sur tous leurs
initiatives d'innovation
au sens large
en termes de recherche quand on est à
plusieurs dès qu'on échange avec
d'autres personnes on avance plus vite
c'est pour ça que nous retrouvons ici
dans ce site tous ces ingrédients qui
sont propices pour toutes les personnes
qui souhaitent faire de l'innovation
nous avons ici un sourcing de cerveau
les écoles produisent des ingénieurs
avec un niveau reconnu mondialement qui
fait partie des meilleurs dans le monde
académique nous avons des labos de
recherche à la fois académique et
industriel dans ce haut lieu de paris
saclay avec qui nous échangeons
régulièrement ce que nous cherchons à
développer tout particulièrement ici à
sac les cds partenariat tripartite c'est
ce qu'on doit commencer à faire avec à
la fois d'un côté ses labos de recherche
et des industriels et d'autre part des
académiques et les ingénieurs qui se
trouve chez nous en recherche et
aujourd'hui les partenariats que nous
développons nous en sommes convaincus
vont permettre de d'avancer beaucoup
plus vite en termes d'innovation et de
ce que nous pouvons offrir à nos clients
le plateau de paris saclay offre aux
entreprises comme nos des interactions à
grande valeur ajoutée avec tout cet
écosystème de la boe de recherche c'est
pour ça que ce site est un lieu
incontournable pour toutes les
entreprises françaises ou
internationales qui souhaitent se
retrouver dans le creuset
d'innovation technologique et de et de
recherche qui est aujourd'hui un élément
essentiel notamment dans l'intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
après l'intelligence artificielle
intéressons nous maintenant à une autre
filière un autre domaine le cantique le
groupe atos qui est présent sur votre
territoire s'est lancé dans cette
aventure très pointu est là aussi pour
développer ces technologies du futur il
faut développer des partenariats
nationaux ou internationaux
atos a accueilli très récemment une
délégation quantique québécoise peut
être le début d'une collaboration outre
atlantique tout de suite les précisions
de philippe duluc directeur big data et
sécurité chez atos et olivier gagnon
gordillo responsable de la stratégie et
du développement québec quantique
nous avons le grand plaisir et l'honneur
d'accueillir aujourd'hui sur le site des
clayes-sous-bois d'atos principal site
de r&d en france d'atos une délégation
québécoise complètement centrée sur les
technologies quantiques donc des
investisseurs des start up et des
membres des clusters québécois non ça
c'est très important pour atos d'avoir
cette capacité de rencontrer des
écosystèmes étrangers en quantum puisque
atos a commencé à développer une
stratégie quantique de plus les années
2016 développé un simulateur un
simulateur quantique se prépare à
développer un supercalculateur hybride
quantique et dans ce cadre là nous
recherchons des partenaires et nous
voulons également participer à la grande
aventure du cantique c'est en fait une
véritable industrie qui est en train de
se développer donc ces écosystèmes sont
très précieux à nos yeux et nous permet
de développer des partenariats et
d'acquérir une connaissance de beaucoup
plus fine de ce qui se fait dans le
monde dans les technologies quantiques
[Musique]
thierry quantique telle initiative qui
regroupe l'écosystème des sciences et
technologies quantiques du québec l'idée
derrière la mission est pourquoi on est
ici aujourd'hui pour en fait créer des
collaborations et même amplifié ce qui a
déjà été fait par le passé on a déjà eu
quelques collaborations avec la france
en termes de science et technologie
quantique on est très heureux d'être ici
aujourd'hui pour visiter finalement
l'écosystème de paris saclay on passa
par atos et on en a visité les
laboratoires de ses 2 m qui en même
temps le profité pour rencontrer
quelques stades il parle un peu de
mariages avec des start up du québec et
des startups françaises
[Musique]
cet échange entre atos et cette
délégation québécoise est un exemple
parmi d'autres de ce qui se joue dans
l'écosystème paris saclay les start up
ne s'y trompe pas elle espère gagner en
visibilité en s'installant ici sur votre
territoire et c'est bien parti pour
qu'ils n'y alice cette start up a
remporté le concours spring 50 dans la
catégorie santé elle travaille en
collaboration étroite avec le n s paris
saclay l'école normale supérieure nous
avons rencontré son sillon cyril gilbert
[Musique]
chez kia lice on développe et
commercialise un traitement chimique
innovant et breveté qui permet
d'améliorer la performance des tests
diagnostiques in vitro par exemple des
tests rapides tellement de l'être on a
tous utilisés durant la causerie de 19
mais on améliore la limite de détection
de ces tests cette technologie qu'on
utilise un traitement chimique donc
breveté qui a été développé inventé par
mon associé claude noguès avec plus de
10 années de recherche au sein de la nes
cachant qui est maintenant le nes paris
saclay où est hébergée actuellement
finalistes
sirigu
spring
c'est un peu la mecque des start up de
paris-saclay donc l'occasion de
rencontrer d'autres start-up innovantes
dans le domaine de la santé mais pas que
la possibilité aussi de rentrer pour
rencontrer des industriels laboratoires
pharmaceutiques développeurs de tester
gnostique donc toujours intéressant pour
une start up on est entrain de
commercialiser notre technologie on
cherche aussi les partenaires donc
c'était pertinent de rencontrer nos
industriels aussi l'opportunité de
rencontrer des investisseurs
intéressant pour nous parce qu'on est en
train de lever un tour d'amorçage donc
pour financer la mise à l'échelle de
notre technologie
puis c'était aussi gagner de la
visibilité ce qu'on a bien fait bien
réussi à faire en remportant le concours
de pitch dans le domaine santé avec des
très belles boîtes est également kitsch
est il y avait de la concurrence et puis
un joli jury avec ipsen servier des
fonds d'investissement
donc ça ça a permis de gagner un peu en
visibilité au niveau national ce qui est
le bienvenu dans une période de levée de
fonds et de début de commercialisation
c'était naturel de s'installer à l'onas
paris-saclay puisque encore une fois la
technologie émane de la nes mais juste à
côté de l'ancien laboratoire de claude
donc ça il ya déjà des synergies en
termes de recherche et de danse et
technologique on a un contrat de
collaboration par exemple avec le n est
ce le cnrs aujourd'hui sur un de projets
en interne
et puis c'est également le la
possibilité d'avoir en partage des
instruments qui sont trop onéreux pour
un achat en interne pour kimia l'iss
puis évidemment l'accès à tout un vivier
de plateformes sur lesquelles on peut
avoir accès à ces instruments
d'étudiants et de personnes en thèse qui
travaillent sur des sujets d'intérêt
pour qu'il n'y ait donc c'est finalement
un peu un point central même si on est
éloigné de paris centre c'est quand même
un point central dans le domaine dans
lequel on évolue avec tous les
industriels qui sont déjà
présents sur le plateau des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques des développeurs
d'outils d'analysé in vitro donc c'est
ça fait énormément sens d'être présent
ici sur le plateau
[Musique]
et maintenant notre agenda vous avez
envie de frissonner de vivre un moment
hors sol hors du temps magique ne ratez
pas la funambule tatiana mosuo bon gars
elle évolue sur un fil à 20 mètres de
haut pour une traversée de son maître à
haut risque au dessus de la perspective
de marta pan l'une des oeuvres d'art
public majeur de saint quentin en
yvelines ce sera le 10 juillet et enfin
deux expositions pour les curieux et les
amoureux d'architecturé la société du
grand paris et l'architecte dominique
perrault présente une exposition
immersive sur le plus grand projet
urbain d'europe c'est jusqu'au 13
juillet à l'espace richaud dans
l'enceinte de l'ancien hôpital royal
sont présentés des cartographies
historique du grand paris du réseau
ferré francilien et des quartiers des 68
future gare voilà de quoi préparer la
rentrée et enfin à l'exposition
territoire en transformation imagine
l'espace public de demain en
s'intéressant aux mouvements de la terre
et l usage qu on en fait il y à un focus
sur le campus urbain avec le projet de
lisières vous avez jusqu'au 10 juillet
pour découvrir cette exposition c'est à
versailles dans le futur écoquartier de
gally voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
je vous souhaite un très bel été et je
vous retrouve très vite pour un numéro
de paris saclay tués
[Musique]